[Music]  as you are probably aware republican  candidate newt gingrich's popularity  continues to grow i mean this guy out of  nowhere became the surprise front-runner  in the republican presidential field and  uh as you can imagine we do political  humor  on the show  so i thought now more than ever it's  crucial that we have a newt gingrich  impersonator  andy i mean yes i've been asking you  all right good just give me the wig yeah  just do the wig come on andy people love  it  yeah  that's very good see  it makes people so happy  hey andy let's see some other newt faces  come on you can do it  [Applause]  oh no one wants that  oh i need calista in here callista  darling  thank you  [Applause]  ah  oh  [Laughter]